[Música]
boa tarde pessoas
eu me chamo josé silva
sou uma mulher é trans resignada e tenho
53 anos sede para chegar a essa idade
como uma pessoa é travesti ou transexual
já que a estatística de vida dessas
pessoas são de 35 a 36 anos de thaty
perdoa ser chorar quando eu falo ser uma
mulher trânsito recebi nada é porque
recentemente eu passei pelo processo de
transgenitalização
é a readequação sexual isso no beija sem
mais nem menos melhor de que um
atravessei ou as pessoas transexuais que
passa que não passaram por esse processo
até porque há-de a de 42 75 nos dá
direito a retificação ea mudança de
gênero
mesmo sem passar pelo processo
transexualizador honra
quando criança eu fui proibida de
brincar com aqueles brinquedos ao qual
eu queria brincar que era a boneca
olhava pra minha amiguinha de lado eu
não entendia por que eu não tinha
aquela genitália e eram tudo muito
confuso pra mim porque uma criança com
23 anos de uma família muito pobre
rejeitada
tá criada dentro de um prostíbulo por
prostitutas
eu sofri todo tipo de preto feito quando
criança
apanhei na rua
apanhei na escola eu era chamar de
[ __ ] de [ __ ] bienne coisas que eu
mesmo tão jovem
eu não entendia porque era uma criança
bastante afeminados
eu nasci menino e menina
[Música]
kaká e sem tente não sabia eu não
entendi o que era ser homem nem mulher
e tudo isso eu aprendi na sociedade que
eu cresci
a rua foi o palco da minha história eu
sofri muitas violências eu não teve
muitas oportunidades
engraçado quando a randon a travesti
passa na faculdade
o passa no concurso público
elas são capas de jornais por que é tão
difícil a gente ver essa realidade nessa
população
a rua à noite ela tem
se paga pedágio na rua ea gente é
colocada sei nenhum respeito a gente
perde todos os direitos que se possa
imaginar como ser humano ou como uma
cidadã brasileira
eu tenho direito de votar guy impostos
quando eu realmente vou procurar esses
direitos direito pra a travesti não
existe aqui tem vagas para mulheres
a travesti não respeita o meu gênero
respeito à minha identidade de gênero
porque aqueles clientes aqueles clientes
que abrem a porta pra mim à noite
durante o dia ele fecha mas são vários
tipos de portas que são fechada para
essa população políticas públicas
eu trabalho eu faço eu luto não tem como
fazer política pública voltada para
essas pessoas sem ser provocativa
eu recebo de 10 a 15 pessoas petês
queremos ajuda psicológica
a autoestima algum tratamento
odontológico atendimento psicológico
passar para por um assistente social
para reivindicar seus direitos
a assessoria jurídica às vezes sofrem
violência
física precisa ir a uma delegacia de
crimes homofóbicos que nós temos aqui em
joão pessoa e de 30 em 30 dias
eu vou à rua eu fico junto com elas eu
abraço elas eu levo comida para elas
porque eu aprendi quando levava
preservativos para heresia madrinha a
camisinha e um gel não mata minha fome e
comer três vezes num dia básico na vida
tem um ser humano
nós temos joão pessoa é o ambulatório de
pessoas travestis e transexuais que
funciona dentro do clementino fraga e
esse ambulatório existe uma equipe
preparada capacitadas profissionais de
saúde que vai desde o psicólogo ou
psiquiatra urologista ginecologista
fonoaudiólogo assistente social pra
receber essas pessoas pra ajudar essas
pessoas dentro do processo de transição
falando que um processo de transição a
pessoa não é obrigada a passar pelo
momento pelo um tratamento de hormônio
terapia não é obrigado a achar que o
processo de transição ele é um protocolo
ele tá numa caixinha prontinho aí não
não é você que te começa não existe
idade para o processo de transição é a
estatística de vida dessas pessoas que
eu falei é de 35 a 36 ano
hoje de janeiro até hoje nós temos
86 pessoas travestis e transexuais
mortas som cruel da ti é como se fosse
uma erva daninha facas facas faca corte
xampu são os objetos no anos são
terríveis
devagarzinho é terminar a nossa
população
a nossa gente nós temos 99% aliás
desculpa 90% de travestis e mulheres
traz se prostituindo na rua e 100% delas
em buscas de melhores oportunidades que
isso nunca acontece né
aqui nós temos o cap da dândara foi
horrível
foi muito cruel a morte dessa
travesseiro e uma repercussão nacional e
internacional também foi a de andar a ea
verônica balbino e foi de uma crueldade
horrível a morte dessas duas meninas
quantas pessoas estão ao lado de vocês
será que existe algum através chip será
que existe algum homem strans
será que existe algumas mulheres trans
quem de vocês já deram a oportunidade
para essas pessoas
quem vocês assentaram um banco de praça
pra conversar com essas pessoas unidades
para travestis e transexuais
é como uma flecha de luz a gente pega e
torna ela no canhão de claridade
parem de nos matar
deixe luz ser felizes
[Aplausos]